今天这堂课的主要议题是歌词
段落的修改与技巧
我们首先先来念一段韵脚诗
这首韵脚诗叫做醒不过来的
喜欢回游在鱼缸要怎么数羊
我一直深陷在那些美好的过往
密闭的鱼自行捏造
对水过敏的想象
醒不过来的梦
该死的冗长
玻璃破碎后
女士拍打在地上
唯一还在呼吸的晃
接下来我们要小聊一下
之前课堂上有分享过的阅读
阅读是投资报酬率最高的事情
但是切记
阅读不能专注在某一个人的某一项著作
那你的知识营养会失衡
阅读应该像杂食性动物一样
什么都摄取针砭时事的论述
文小说轻松的散文杂记
旅游杂记
或者是所有的新诗诗歌都去广泛的吸收
请说出个人的一个独立的见解
这是我一再的强调
有什么好处呢
改变观念
你会得到一个新的世界
就像建筑来讲好了
一般人对建筑的理解可能用行政区
用街道来划分
像这个可能是金融区
这个可能是文教区
但是呢一旦你改变观念的时候
你看到的世界是不一样的
这时候建筑变成什么
这时候建筑变成城市的面貌
城市的表情
城市的气质就是这样子
改变观念
你就得到了一个新的世界
文字是用来记录语言
而歌词则是用来替旋律说故事
怎么理解这个问题
难道旋律不能自己说故事吗
很好
接下来我们用一首demo die让大家体会这个问题
而这个demo带很特别
它是一首电影主题曲的主打歌叫听爱
所以我们王力宏老师
或者说力宏同学所做的一个demo
那这个demo非常的好听
我就在想这么多堂课里面
不妨我们就扎扎实实地放一首带给大家听
为什么
因为流行音乐的创作核心就是先有曲再有词
再来编曲
再配唱
再混音
可是过程中课堂的过程中
同学们没有听过半首的demo die
巅峰带到底长什么样子
让我们很难得的听一下这首精彩的demo
We need more
I find us in a modifi
Sa feeling for my dre
同学们是不是听到一种情绪
情绪就是感受像古典乐一样很爱听
但是它没有故事孤独的情绪
你可以理解成
那么音乐里面的背景空间或是环境
但是只有歌词可以赋予它故事情节和人物
这个就是我刚刚强调的
歌词是替旋律说故事的
很好听
Say what you want
因为爱我
有创作的时候就是这样子
我们先把旋律的段落拼出来
待会给大家看一个格式
几个音节
段落
通常我都是边听边用手写
在纸上记录他的段落行距
Who you are
But it was when
We don't want to be
这是非常的好听
难得的一堂课
像这样子
他现在有个旋律
然后旋律是情怀情怀
只有画面感
空间跟环境
但是他的故事线必须用文字去鲜明的去凸显它
不管是他的故事情节
或者是刚刚强调的人物
怎么理解这个问题呢
刚刚听力宏同学的这个demo有点像古典乐
整个情绪满满很优美
但是好像没有剧情在里面进行
没有人物在对话
就像说你到了一个很漂亮的森林
感受很放松
但是声音里面没有故事
或者是你到了一个海边听海浪的声音
很疗愈
但是呢没有情节
这个就是我一再强调的歌词就是为旋律说故事
一般词曲创作者的demo外面是听不到的
所以大家很有耳福
听到了天王级的一个demo
这种现象是
基本上只有在我们课程上才有可能发生
那刚刚听的时候
大家留意它有很多的段落
那通常段落就我来讲
我都会用这样子的形式去呈现
那到时候一样会有一个视频的辅助
它里面的格式就是音乐的段落
你填词的时候再根据这个段落去填词
这个非常重要
为什么有些快节奏的
像那种rap的歌词
天呐我听了好几次
一不停的倒带不停的倒带抒情
慢版的歌比较好听
你可能花个半个小时就可以把段落理清
这个段落理清楚
有助于你歌词填进去的时候不会卡位
所以卡位是明明前面是三个音
你却填成四个字
这个到时候可能填好词之后
你自己稍微练习着唱可能都不顺畅
所以呢刚刚推荐的这种格式
你就是用很简单的一通常我是手写稿
这个只是为了上课方便
我把它整理出来
就是一张简单的a four纸
然后demo带听边听边画边听边画
譬如说可能像山南飘去三凹下
它的音节的联动是七个音
七个音完之后四个音
所以你歌词不能填八三
虽然加起来的总数是对的
但是其实基本上是唱的时候会很辛苦
歌手
而且会被退稿
所以呢它的段落必须符合你的韵脚的结构
这个是非常重要
再来我们看你的声音
听见爱情
它很明显它就是四个音
四个音
但是你不能填成你声音
听见了爱情后面多少个音
前面少个音
所以前面那个结构拼出来的结构是很重要
它是基础
像建筑的一个蓝图
你必须在蓝图上去盖歌词大楼
所以你要盖鸽子大楼的时候
你的建筑蓝图精准度必须是对的
接下来分享的范例是诛仙一个电玩
一开始的歌名叫我修炼
然后呢他们觉得我修炼好像没有记忆点
也因此呢后续我又写了两个歌迷让他调
一个是天地无边
一个是先练神仙的仙
最后呢他们又觉得好像还可以有更多的可能性
我又想了一个歌名叫逍遥剑
就三点水一个尖
这首歌我写了四个歌名
记得歌词这项行业是服务业
你必须全力地去满足对方的需求
因为真正使用的是他们
他们花大笔的预算在打歌
他们一定有他们的考量
我从不跟他们争辩这个问题
所以呢歌词是服务业
心思才是自由业
耶一开始我的主歌花非花
故事一页页被风刮轻飘过皇城
琉璃瓦风飞沙
结局又落在谁的家
一笔带走谁的天涯
后来他们觉得说里面好像有两个词汇
他们不喜欢
就是轻飘过皇城
他们觉得皇城这个字眼
跟游戏比较没有直接的关联
好就改成飘过青云门
这是电网里面的一个元素
然后再来就是一笔带走天涯
他们就觉得好像不太对劲
我就改成一笔画出谁的天涯
挑一个比较大的段落
话说梦已落
就不该四海漂泊
我说秦已走
这不动如山是我
这不过就两行
他改了四个地方
一个地方是就不该四海漂泊
后来改成就不该继续漂泊
他想说四海好像很辽阔
没有聚焦
他享受更深入的情感
所以就不该继续漂泊
中文是不是很好用
我说中文汉
这是孤立语
一个字一个音
对我们作词者来讲是个福音
我说梦已走
后来改成不走情已锁
诶
觉得改的好像比较好
不走琴已锁
锁起来的锁诶好像比较好
然后接下来一行
这几番风雨总是惹来几番离愁
一样有改
改成这几番风雨总是捎来几番离愁
就是骚
就是记的意思
你好像真的比较美
所以对方的要求是有道理的
接下来段落是全部推翻
全部推翻也很特别
磨砺自己的技术和耐心
微笑
将错过的缘分
开头这江湖刀光剑影从来不讲温柔
修道成仙也就没有借口
我觉得地板很好啊
对方不要后来改成什么呢
改成将错过当成缘分
起了头嫩绿的青春在枝芽冒出了温柔
我微笑等花开后的自由
诶好像也可以也不错
就自我挑战
所以呢接受修改歌词是对的
因为磨练你的文笔
磨练你对文字掌控的能力
接下来的段落它只保留六个字而已
整段都修改到了副歌的地方
到底是魔是佛还是先我修炼
有没有我修炼变成关键字
所以我第一遍的歌名叫做我修炼循证道
毅然挥剑诛仙一瞬间
河阳城下横笛重现
我修炼邪不胜正
我虔诚地默念这整段副歌哦
他只保留了六个字
就是我虔诚的默念好
第二遍怎么改呢
天地无边
却仿佛有着一条线
我默默修炼成就一段姻缘
这个是歌名的来源
循证道为你毅然挥剑一瞬间修道成仙
我虔诚的默念
有时候修改歌词是看需求
看委托方的需求
不是说你填词的语词不好
不是的
修改歌词有很多种
一个是唱的不顺
明明最后的开口音你填成闭口音
滋滋滋
这只是填词的时候最忌讳放在A2的最后一行
应该进入副歌的时候
你有些key要升高
你有些key升高的时候
你压滋滋是什么心事样子城市哇
你怎么去接副歌啊
接不了
所以第一个修改歌词的时候是因为唱的不对
唱的不顺
那第二项修改的理由才是不够美
不够精彩
不够有创意
这也会被要求修改
第三个叫非战之罪
所以说非战之罪是双方对垒打仗的时候
你打败了
但是不是你的军队不够精良
不是你的战略错误
而是刚好有一场天灾
有个地变影响了你部队的行径
这叫非战之罪
不是你战争方所负担的一个责任和罪责
线上游戏有时候更换歌词的段落
不是你写的不够好
而是他们去考量
有时候角色放太多
太太自如了
有时候觉得说哪个空间要放进去
这种调整是很灵活的
所以这是第三种
一个是唱着不顺
一个是本来就写的不好
另外一个是想要有不同的发展跟想象空间
我刚好强调一个观念
记得歌词是服务业
诗才是自由业
所以呢我们必须很精准的去服务委托方
他可能是个歌手
可能是一张专辑
可能是一个活动
可能是一部电影去满足对方的需求
才是我们在这个职业的岗位上
所应尽的专业水平
但是也有例外的例外
通常呢就是很罕见的发生
有一首歌叫娘子
这娘子这首歌呢很特别
就是说当初我把歌词填好之后呢
啊我想说啊
应该我的工作结束了啊
周同学就进去录音室里面配上了
他就唱唱唱
他通常唱歌有时候会提醒
觉得这个间奏应该在放歌词进去
他也没有打电话给我
他可能想说就那么几句吧
然后他就把他唱进去了
而且他觉得他没有错
为什么呢
他唱的歌词是原来歌词里面的段落
他把他做某种程度的排列组合
他觉得反正还是你写的歌词还有什么关系
可是我的心就揪在那里呀
我觉得就那么几行
你跟我讲
我可以写得更好
让整首歌的歌词延伸的想象有更多
他就不要两个就僵持在那里
我甚至跟他讲说这首歌的版税我不要了
你可不可以重唱
因为求好心切嘛
那时候刚进来这个圈子
总希望拿得出手是最好的作品
她不愿意啊
而且嘴巴长在他的脸上啊
你不能压着他唱吧
或者是我去补唱吧
这不可能发生吗
后来就觉得嗯他也不管
然后气氛有点僵持住
后来当然是我这边让步
因为毕竟是他的专辑
而且是他在唱
我只是求好心切
想要重写
给我时间
给我一个下午
甚至几个小时
我可以给你更好的歌词
他就是不要
后来我学到教训了
从此以后只要周同学在录音室里面配上呢
我就会飘飘飘飘飘过去
我就出现在那里
避免他突然想要干嘛
讲到这里
我又想起一段恩怨情仇的往事
很久很久以前有首歌叫刀马旦
然后那时候是天后李玟唱的
周冬雪是这首歌的制作人
那首歌也是惊涛骇浪
我人跟到录音室去
我在想说
我当初跟去是好事还是坏事
我都不晓得
因为我人在了
我就没地方躲
我想说我去看一下李文
你知道吗
去的时候本来有一大段的旋律
要用京剧的唱腔拉长音去绕
诶
也蛮好的
然后我们的周同学周天王突然觉得不对
这里面应该有歌词
然后我人就在现场
于是呢我就被压在录音室的现场
我大概用了十几分钟
我印象中还没有超过20分钟
我就把这个段落写好了
那个应该是最极具压力的状况下
写出自己还满意的作品
A通常有压力的状况下
你会写不好
甚至有时候我写歌会逃避
怎么逃避呢
让这个环节各位同学不要学
就是说会关机
你知道吗
很久很久以前
我那时候传讯息给个制作人
他就是SHE的制作人
我一直逃避
一直逃避
一直不写不写
但不写不是写不出来
而是觉得好像没有更好的想法idea
然后呢我就传个讯息
我传什么讯息呢
我说致歉
讲说脱稿的原因
什么时候在教
然后讲完之后我就传出去
传出去之后就关机
我就关机了
我就但这个方法还是不要学
就说好像哦你跟对方讲原因的
可是怕他回
你怕看到他回什么内容
你知道吗
因为我已经脱稿了
我就是传出去之后就关机了
大多数的状况下歌词写不出来
我就去做别的事情
我觉得这也是个方法
就说你不要硬碰硬
有些浅层用于结构创意
就是牢记脑子没有更好的亮点
也就是暂时搁下
可能去看一本书
可能看个电视或者跟朋友聊聊天
喝个咖啡都可以
除非你是很自律的人
你跟你的交稿时间对抗
你有本事
或者是说你有能力还是能在期限内把它完成
就像我们的力宏同学
我跟他聊过天
我说有时候创作遇到瓶颈
你怎么办
我跟他讲说
我就是会算是某种程度的回避掉
我要面对的工作
我去做别的事情
但是我们力宏同学的人格特质是我就跟你对干
我就跟你面对面
我就是在期限内交稿的期限内把作品交出去
这个是看个人的性格而定
接下来我们话题回到刚刚的刀马旦
于是呢我就在录音室里面
还不是另外一个空间哦
就是配唱后面的沙发
把那段本来没有格子的段落给完成
而且重点是我没有修改
就是后来我发现并不是我天赋异禀
而是我创作的当下
刚好找对了一个文字的节奏感跟创意的主轴
这个很重要哦
你一旦掌握了你的创作的顺畅度就会很高
我等一下念给大家听
你就知道原来如
因此接下来我要分享一段本来没有要填的歌词
一口粮
一张床
一面墙
一扇窗
我洒下一地月光
一次种下一亩高粱
一个人在北大荒
一碗热汤温暖了我一个晚上
一匹苍狼一身风霜
走过丝路回家乡
因为我开头都用一有没有
我写的时候想说完蛋了怎么办
突然灵光乍现
诶
我干脆用一开头
我一旦掌握了这个创作的一个主轴
或者是节奏感
就写得很快
歌词的修改会锻炼我们的能力
这样子的一个能力呢会体现在你日后的创作上
你会更经得起别人的要求
而不是没有抗压性哇
天哪要修改就崩溃了
整段话你就激发翻脸了啊
绝对不能这样子
有时候歌迷的修改还算是最轻微的一个考验
最难的考验其实什么段落你知道吗
不是歌名
也不是主歌l a two
而是副歌
副歌是记忆点
你明明酝酿那个记忆点
你才能往前铺成他的A2A2
那里连副歌的第一行都换掉
那个整个节奏是乱调的
基本上副歌的基点被换掉之后
前面多多少少做局部的修改以后
如果你们中间有谁真的进入这一行
不要抱怨修改
甚至不要抱怨好几个版本
这是这个工作这个领域应有的态度
跟专业
记得要做到专业的程度